avec les sondages qui ponctuent chaque
semaine l'engouement autour des
présidentielles n'a jamais commencé
aussitôt trois candidats vous le voyez
qu'ils sont dans un mouchoir de poche
potentiellement tous qualifiable pour le
second tour dans la presse à la radio ou
à la télévision on ne parle que de ça et
les invités en plateaux sont tous amenés
à donner leur avis c'est le cas de
l'humoriste philippe chevallier qui
était l'invité de jordan de luxe et qui
fait prononcer en faveur de la
présidente et rennes marine le pen pour
l'instant je la mettrais chez marine
d'accord parce que je la trouve trop
lequel il ya une base populaire est ce
que les téléspectateurs ont surtout
relevé c'est sa justification par
rapport aux origines de sa femme vous
savez moi ma femme est sénégalaise
donc j'aime là dessus j'ai pas de leçon
de la recevoir alors philippe chevallier
at il dérapé
alors moi j'aime pas cette question
philippe sueur badiate ils dérapent lors
voilà qu'est ce que souvenant penser
j'ai envie de plus vous demander qu'est
ce que vous en pensez bonsoir elisabeth
lévy merci d'être là là elle ramenait la
une de causeur oui au champ d'honneur
puisque vous êtes toujours là dedans
voilà merci à france inter ras-le-bol de
payer pour se faire insulter ras le bol
de payer pour se faire insulter vous
savez que vous allez voilà michele hider
sur est faible sur rtl où ça vous allez
faire recette ici
prévoit la pression comme vous le sentez
merci florian tiani qui qu'on aime
fondateur de leur french comme excellent
florian qui a bien dégagée sur les côtés
bravo et sembles bas vous êtes bien plus
beau vous savez et julie garnier
oratrice nationale de la france soumise
alors déjà j'aurais conservé sur cette
histoire / philippe chevallier est ce
que ça vous dérange ce qu'il a dit ou
est-ce que pas du tout vous dites ils
disent qu'ils veulent votre pour qu'il
veut et puis c'est la phrase derrière
qui a interpellé chez lui sur les
réseaux sociaux vous plongera cassé dit
non non c'est très rare qu'un artiste en
autriche qui seront honnêtement je vote
pour le pen phocéen s'est imposé la
première fois mais non c'est la première
fois qu'ils s'expriment en mai mais
honnêtement voilà après la frappe
derrière ma faim les sénégalais c est
moi c'est très maladroit mais voilà je
trouve ça fou quand même incroyable
qu'un artiste voilà c'est ça n'aille
jamais croyable
moi j'ai fait ce qu'il veut avec qui
elle était jeune il va bien qu'il veut
plutôt à gauche plutôt voilà
mais oui c'est vrai que tous ceux qui
votent à gauche le dise voilà la sarthe
et ça même si à 40 et 60 heures
courage il ya un certain courage à le
dire et peut-être aussi le fait que
philippe chevallier que j'aime beaucoup
nous avons travaillé mon ami c'est
exagéré mais je lui ai déjà en contraire
poteau voilà voilà et que je trouve
vraiment un garçon très sympathique et
courageux mais je pense que s'il était
en pleine carrière il n'osera pas lui
dire je connais des artistes des
comédiens tout à fait connu qui votent
et moureaux qui aimerait botter zemmour
c'est lui qui se présente et qui m'ont
dit mais jamais on le dire parce que le
lendemain on ne travaillera plus long
qu'il ya quand même une atmosphère on
devrait quand même s'interroger y
compris les gens de gauche sur qu'est ce
qui se passe dans un pays où des adultes
n'ose pas dire ce qu'il pense
ce qu'il pense politique bon où ils sont
ou en gros ils sont obligés d'être de
gauche maintenant sur la phrase voulait
que l'arrêté qui n'ont pas de notion la
phrase en fait c je trouve que c'est
maladroit d'ailleurs ça ne sert plus à
rien vous voyez bien que zemmour est
juif et les nazis pied quand même donc
déroulé on a plus de blond ça avec cela
c'est un peu maladroit mais ça témoigne
aussi du climat c'est à dire que oui dit
je vote le pen on va vous traiter de
[ __ ] de raciste
or je mets au défi quelqu'un aujourd'hui
de m'expliquer en quoi les racistes
c'est bien c'est bien ou du mal sur la
fin ça sert
à ça ne suffit pas pour jouer les xénons
et raciste ou pas - non non non non non
ça c'était moi plutôt que de me dire ans
elizabeth alors que jamais que quelqu'un
me cite une phrase raciste de
matignon l'histoire des prénoms c'est
pas raciste saint antoine à paul et on
était raciste
c'est pas maladroit avec dialyses et
totalement maladroit c'est bien aussi
non mais pétain c'est très compliqué
mais le débat a été condamné à mort avec
des anciens immigration et
merci merci gilles verdez d'habitude
vous dites que je suis là parce que
causeur ne gagne pas d'argent là vous
l'avez pas dit c'est dommage vous avez
merci merci vous m'avez tendu la perche
que je voulais parce que précisément si
vous voulez ce qui s'est passé pendant
cinquante ans c'était la phrase je suis
contre l'immigration où je trouve qu'il
ya trop d'immigration en france que
beaucoup d'immigrés prononce au
demeurant vous qualifier de raciste eh
bien il n'y a rien de raciste dans cette
phrase on peut considérer que la france
ne peut pas accueillir plus d'immigrés
sont achevés moins du monde ratier et
c'est le cas à vrai dire de 70% des
procès pardon mais c'est pas le sujet en
fait qu'est ce qui se passe n'est pas le
sujet en fait oui là on n'est pas en
train de faire un débat social fiction
est ce que ça vous dérange cette phrase
devenue bah moi ce qu'une dérange c'est
juste que j'en ai un peu marre société
transparence on dit pour qui les gens
votent s'en fout un peu pour qu'ils
votent chevalier on s'en fout de votre
pour qui veut d'abord quand
effectivement la justification ma femme
est sénégalaise je comprends pas la
sortie là je veux dire c'est un truc que
je comprends pas ils votent pour qui il
veut maintenant à cordes content ça se
justifier des raisons pour lesquelles
personne lui a demandé de se justifier à
saxon est très bien me prenant il avait
qu'à pas il avec aplomb mise à kapalua
que dans une société comme la nôtre non
mais ils sont convaincus si vous voulez
la tcsp de la vessie voulu non
maladroitement il ya un an il avait qu'à
pas lui personne n'a obligé à dire poser
la
question alors gilles verdez c'est
terrible pour sa femme enfin quand même
faut se rendre aussi réduire sa femme à
une nationalité donc sous-entendu à une
couleur de peau mais tu as demandé aux
imams s'ils s'allient séville à lui
alors ça mais sénégalaise comme alibi
comme mère et de sa veut encore une fois
nous ramener à l'importance de la
nationalité ou de la couleur de la
légion dans le vote donc ça je suis
désolé c'est qu'il dit
vous comprenez pas
ces racistes arrêté alors guillaume
genton un visa mais tout à l'heure vous
avez dit qu'il s'est permis de dire ça
parce qu'ils n'étaient pas au début de
sa carrière en sous-entendant que
quelqu'un qui dirait ça aujourd'hui
pourrait ruiner sa carrière mais ce
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui c'est
autant il ya vingt ans j'ai fait
je suis désolé on sait qu'à des millions
de gens qui donnent cette fougue et
encore d'autres non
mais regardez
les spécificités du danger mais n'est dû
ni ce que dira demain
vomi
ça devrait être comme j'adore mais la
mairie c'est pareil c'est aussi
prouverait aucun artiste qui vous dira
publiquement donc à part jean yves
chevalier et c'est pour ça la raison
excusez moi sur ce plateau on a plein de
gens qui veut ouvertement zemmour qui
viennent
mais sorti leurs blogs ces petits
déjeuners travail lui d'accord mais ça
se dit plus qu'il va penser à jouer
avec du show beach que tu vois un
chanteur qui vend des millions disent
non au réveil je vois tu eric zemmour
s'est jouée plus en plus de fans le dis
jamais mais chez qui il est gentil
non mais je vois de plus en plus de gens
qui le disent dans un placard marché toi
oui séville plus en plus de gens qui
le showbiz
non
pas du tout
je t'adore tu es mon ami et l'a ratée
dans le voit même
ceux qui avaient dit qu'ils votaient
pour sa cause ils ont été exclus
des fauteuils roulants elle est allée
aux jeux tels que je pense
nomination il ya eu des problèmes en
question était tellement ils ont des
faux dali ils ont beaucoup de talent
mais cette histoire est tellement
talentueux salon peut pas se voit là il
passe dans tous les pays il y avait
perdu mais combien il a eu des problèmes
il aura
alors que philippe chevrier il dit ça je
voterai marine le pen si respectable et
on doit le respecter et dit ce qu'il
veut en revanche c'est la libye qui fait
ce qu'il veut oui ma femme est
sénégalaise ça c'est zéro
pour prouver qu'on n'est pas homophobe
dit j'ai des amis pdg au moment où j'ai
des amis juifs quand on est parti
c'est que c'est maladroit mais si on
danse je suis loin vous comprenez bien
pourquoi il le dit eh oui je le dis
parce que sinon ça ce n'est qu'il
arrêtera que l'idée des deux salles aux
primés du quotidien mais c'est bien mais
ça latine sommes tout à fait d'accord
j'essaye juste d'expliquer sa maladresse
et jan charouz assurent qu'ils évoluent
oui mais dans ce cas là pourquoi il le
dit moi je suis d'accord avec fabrice di
vizio c'est à dire le jour ici
aussi on a des isoloirs et si on est
censé le faire dans le respect des lois
lors de 2 200 machines en vue de le dire
il le dit c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui
fera date dans sa requête déjà que ça
bouge sans opposition ensuite
l'explication qu'il a faim dirait du
gilles verdez donc moi je suis désolé ce
n'est pas rien qui va pardon ça vous
choque par exemple quand des artistes de
gauche c'est voler ce qui arrive
absolument tout le temps fondées grande
tribune pour dire
ac on lui a posé la question
on lui a posé la question il a répondu
l'europe y accueillir ça vous regarde
pas est ce qui se passait aux gens tant
rigide bardot alain delon
aller chercher
ensuite bardot
tu veux donner le dernier titre de
brigitte bardot et des personnalités
je me rappelle il ya quelques années
j'étais une pétition contre la lula la
pénalisation de la prostitution ça
s'appelait touche pas ma peut-être plein
de gens assez connus qui était donc
parti avait avait signé et bien civile
temporise ont tous eu des emmerdes on a
même agri j'étais semblant j'ai fait
semblant dire qu'il n'avait pas signé
parce que dans ce milieu si vous sortez
du cadre vous risquez de perdre vos
chroniques
ça c'est une bonne question a raison
c'est vrai qu'elle a la question la
question je vous le dis elle a prétendu
c'est vrai que des artistes qui disent
qu'ils votent à droite voire l'extrême
droite il n'y en avait jusqu'à indiquer
aux gens ton mépris 2 d'exemple alain
delon brigitte bardot gesetz pas buvant
des 10 sur les 6 derniers mois mais vit
à cheval des salles et les chansons
seraient multiples réponses alors ben
oui mais donc tu vois des mecs connu là
des mecs qui pensent et disent qu'il n'y
a plus de temps tu vois tu vois de
manjul dire ouais nan mais qu'ils se
racontent n'ignorait pas dire ouais je
vote marine le pen même s'il est ce que
c'est pourquoi tous mes
liens jordana c'est un accord qui sera
brisée vidéo non chez moi je me
demandais ce que c'est pas vrai aussi
pour jean luc mélenchon bons noms comme
en question n'est pas la réponse
antennes on dort là non jean luc
mélenchon week end je sais que c'est un
modèle assez américain de des célébrités
qui disent pour qu'ils votent non moi je
pense que personne ne devrait dire pour
qui et vote c'est quelque chose de très
personnel et moi je pense que ces gens
là ils ont des fans et moi je pense que
les femmes peuvent être influencés et on
connaît pas les artistes on les connaît
pas dans leur vie et ça peut être un
gros naze dans la vie il peut te fait
rire et bien chanter au travail et ça
veut pas dire qu'il aura la science
infuse au niveau du vote donc moi je
suis contre alors on parler d'eric
zemmour est un instant c'est vrai que de
plus en plus on voit des gens dire je
vais voter eric zemmour s'est monté à
cerignola dans les rues mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya aucun artiste encore à me l'a
dit je vais voter eric zemmour tiens
voilà alors juste des choses que vous ne
verrez pas
à parler aux gens tant qu'il ya des
artistes qui va nous les données
d'ailleurs kanye west qui dit qu'il veut
donald trump
[Applaudissements]
deux démocrates l'arrêt du buteur il a
raison kenny wayne shepherd dit que ça
pourrait arriver demain et
qu'aujourd'hui je parle pas des artistes
du village
vous êtes peut-être en avant c'est
peut-être très optimiste parce que la
réalité il en avant surtout sur la
coiffure
la trêve mais la réalité c'est que ça ne
devrait pas poser de problème le seul
problème c'est que dans le showbiz on
considère encore que est de gauche et la
vérité et est de droite une hérésie
alors une maladie même